observez la nouvelle vie de mon ex femme
c'est comme tomber sur un feuilleton que
l'on connaît bien et s'apercevoir que
l'acteur principal a été remplacé par un
acteur plus jeune et sans cervelle
félicitations à vous félicitations
passeur bêta grand écrivain et tu sais
pourquoi
c'est parce que les courageuses dans la
vérité on veut tous les deux la même
chose à lui dans ta chambre s'envoyer en
l'air et que jamais sans voix
el bez à droite et à gauche c'est pas
tout à fait pareil
j'te délire tourner la page envoie en
l'air je m'envoie en l'air génial c'est
vrai que j'ai très exactement vingt
minutes on a fait une seconde tête jeudi
même ordre
je ferais pas ça si j'étais toi bonne je
vis là bas il couche avec un tadjik à
presque 100% de chances de te réveiller
avec une mst
merci pour le tuyau cool quand tu veux
il faut quittera marie tu charmante huet
aventures des célèbres juste ce qu'il
faut c'est tout ce dont peut rêver un
écrivain si j'étais à sa place je
masculin sur primo publicité
c'est ça la photo est choisi pour mettre
tout près parce que là tu as une tête de
psychopathe
c'est ma chemise fait et c'était tu veux
dire ne dis pas que tout ça est ce que
je vous pose une question que va se
tenir
je peux rester chez toi ce sera oui au
bio je savais que tu es unique à propos
de l'amour je me sens moins cynique
victoire
que certains jours je doute avoir pris
la bonne décision
je repense à nous à notre histoire et
tout ce qu'on n'a pas fait comme il
fallait
si on avait une deuxième chance ça
pourrait être tellement dur
j'entendais battre mon coeur j'entendais
le bruit humains que nous faisions assis
là sans aucun doute de gauche même
lorsque leur sécurité au travail la
pièce